hello and welcome to the reason live
stream I'm Zach Weissmuller uh today uh
we're going to be talking with apology
shrinivasan a venture capitalist and
former CTO at coinbase and author of the
network State about his one million
dollar public bet on March 17th that one
Bitcoin will be worth a million US
dollars in 90 days today's bitcoin price
was about 28 400 when I checked this
morning Balaji is still on his way to
join us he'll be joining us from
Singapore so he's running a few minutes
behind it's it's very late there so
understandable uh but uh he's when he
joins he's going to explain to us why he
made that bet what his fundamental
concerns are about the state of
America's banking system in the US
dollar and why he thinks Bitcoin is on
the brink of massive worldwide adoption
also joining us to offer his insights is
Lawrence H white uh an economist at
George Mason University specializing in
banking and monetary policy and author
of The recently released book better
money gold Fiat or Bitcoin uh Larry
thank you very much for joining me for
today's conversation
uh thanks Zach thanks for inviting me
so let's start oh wait I see a Balaji
has jumped in let me add him to the
stream oh there he is okay apology
thanks for joining us
hey thanks guys uh just the link just
kept crashing my browser I had to get to
a different computer
um
I can hear you yes
um yep well yeah thanks for joining us
and you know since since you're here uh
let's start with you let's I want to
start with just understanding the bet uh
Balaji and let me pull up a couple
slides here so this is how it all went
down there's a uh pseudonymous Twitter
poster named uh calls himself James
Medlock uh describes himself as a tax
Enthusiast and uh hyperinflation doubter
and says I bet I'll bet anyone one
million dollars that the US does not
enter hyperinflation that of course
being a sort of joke in itself in that
if it went to if we had hyperinflation
the million dollars wouldn't be worth so
much but uh Balaji you jumped in and
said I will to take that fat you buy one
Bitcoin I will send a million US Dollars
that's about 40 to 1 odds as Bitcoin is
worth about twenty six thousand dollars
let me let me cut you off here if you go
down one tweet yeah
um see if you see if you can pull that
up yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna have to uh
pull up your Twitter here in a second uh
but because this is
but uh if you want to describe what
happened and I'll look for it
sure sure so
so basically
um the Fuller context here is in a sense
this event that I've already won and I
bet that I've already lost all right why
okay so the point was to bring attention
to the stealth financial crisis that uh
at the time that I tweeted this that had
not been acknowledged as such
um people were treating it as an
isolated bank failure they were trying
to say that the FED had nothing to do
with it they were trying to say that oh
of course everybody knows how to hedge
um duration risk and it was just you
know one dumb bank manager uh people
were not talking about the fact that the
crypto exits were being closed with
crypto Banks getting shut down and
crypto companies getting assaulted
um people were not talking about the
fact that that is launching fed now in
July uh people are not talking about the
sheer quantity of money that had been
printed or that could be printed under
this both this btfp program and the new
swap lines program they weren't talking
about the fact that you know hundreds of
billions of dollars has been sent out of
local Regional Banks
um and uh they were basically blaming it
on
you the depositor not diligencing your
bank and finding out that the bank was
often insolidated that the Central Bank
impossible in the bank Regulators did
not disclose it
and so the the point of this was
essentially to alert people to that kind
of combination of facts and uh you know
one way of thinking about it is um
uh timing is hard but prepping is easy
and uh you know from like you know back
during code of the early days coverage I
saw this thing coming of China from my
first tweet to actually California
um from Silicon Valley Bank going from
totally functional Bank to having 42
billion wired out of it and another 100
something billion if reports are to be
clear it was about like two days or
three days
um we have uh we have something where if
you look at a bunch of these big stocks
they're like analog and it's digital
death at the end right meaning that
insofar as markets were reflecting
information about the future they
actually weren't because the death at
the end was just digital just kind of
went to zero whether it's svb or like
First Republic these things just look
digital at the end the death is digital
um if you want to look at the discount
window and you look at you know the
money that banks are taking from the fed
that's also like vertical in this past
2008. and on and on please uh you know
there's various quite a few measures
right now that showed the economy is in
Cardiac Arrest of of some form or the
other entering it and a lot of these
things are just kind of going vertical
at the same time and all of that was
being obscured because like Biden was
meeting with like Ted lasso you know
staff of Ted lasso you see that right
right yes and so how do you punch
through that right how do you how do you
go like you know you have CNN you have
vulture journal and like Washington is
reporting on this some somewhat but
they're reporting it on a as a like a
blow by Blue basis like this bank is
going down and this thing has a problem
as opposed to an overall narrative that
puts the facts together in a different
way which says the FED actually killed
the base
um and uh and that's actually the
updated
firefighter right
and uh and that gives a model of what to
expect so Point basically being how do
you punch through that cycle and I
actually a few days earlier had a
different thing where I was just
basically paying people like a thousand
bucks to post about
um you know like like graphs and charts
on this stealth financial crisis and
then mocking that edlot came and he was
like oh and the US will never enter
hyperinflation and so then I was like
okay fine you know why don't we why
don't we take this a little little bet
because I had already set out to
essentially burn money as a public
service to alert people to the self
financial crisis does that make sense
right and if you go and look at my
subsequent tweet can you bring that up
like the reply to that first one
just as in 2008 the Banker's Life
hold on uh
okay uh just in 2008 the bankers live
okay yeah let me uh screen share that
one second
um
of course my
present so
share screen
hi okay
uh here we go so there we go just as in
2008 the bankers lied right exactly so
this was the post that I wanted people
to see
okay it's a reply to the vet post and
essentially lays out a completely
different narrative than what you'd read
in the Press where you you know insofar
as if you're to believe Twitter before
this
um some immigrant engineer in Sunnyvale
is responsible for finding a hidden
insolvency in a footnote of a bank 10q
but Jerome Powell is responsible for
nothing
what the narrative was and I knew
hundreds of like Indian Founders other
Founders who are like I don't trust U.S
banks and moving their money back home
just getting their money the heck out
not knowing what the hell was happening
just knowing they were getting blame for
the bank losing their money
and pulling it all together essentially
just as in 2008 the bankers live this
time the central Bankers the banks and
the bank Regulators have lied to all
dollar holders and depositors not your
typical fractional Reserve situation
there isn't enough in the banks on a
mark to Market basis cover withdrawals
they knew this all through last year and
communicated internally in their coded
language I give a bunch of citations the
keyword is unrealized losses citations
to the FED citations to FDIC citations
of banks themselves quotations to the
banks accountants showing them how to
hide the insolvency and comparing it if
you scroll up a little bit like you know
yeah Uncle Sam bankman freed okay so
just like Sam Bateman freed used your
deposits at FTX to go and buy you know
these crappy assets coins and use
counting tricks he had this pretty
balance sheet remember that yeah use
accounting tricks to fool himself and
others into thinking that he still had
the money but when people came for the
money he wasn't there very similar thing
happened with the banks themselves they
use people's deposits to buy long-dated
U.S treasuries the ultimate ship coming
in a sense they all got destroyed at the
same time the same way because they've
got the same asset in same vendor who
developed devalue it at the same time
which is a fed and uh it's really just
like the failure of central planning you
know it's just in a totally different
way than communism or whatever it's just
another just Central planning complete
face plant where they all make the same
mistake at the same time because all the
you know Innovation or contrariness or
whatever is being leash out of the
system so you know I give some of the
tick tock there if you go to that
citation number eight
um in 2021
um yeah so click that open a new window
this shows and this is getting better
you have to like know like technical
Bond or Bank stuff or whatever to
understand what that is going on here
but if you zoom out a little bit here
um this headline says
in August 2021 banks are binging on
bonds but not because they want to right
so essentially what happened was all
that printed money it crowded out the
normal supply of commercial loans
interest rates are depressed only way
for banks to make money was high
long-term government bonds the only
thing that gave any interest say all
loaded up on them at the same time
Powell and everybody is saying
inflation's a conspiracy theory uh
you're such a loser for saying we're
ever going to have inflation interest
rates are going to be low for a long
time we're going to be patient about
rate hikes in fact if you go back to my
tweet
um okay
um and you go to uh you know the uh
actually if you go to the next tweet
because they only let me put 10 links in
a tweet go into that one yeah just click
that and then show more there click that
scroll down a little bit
to the references
yeah Okay click link number nine link
number and then yeah link number nine
even as late as November 3rd 2021 Powell
is saying that he's going to be patient
on rate hikes
okay so he's baiting everybody in to buy
gigantic amounts of bonds at saying that
rate hikes are going to be slow and
gradual and so on and then what happens
is if you go back uh you know a couple
more tabs
November 22nd 2021 he gets renominated
okay and then he just hikes rates to the
absolute Moon thinking now probably I
mean like my my surmise is that he
thought okay now I can be Paul volcker
I'm safe I'm re-nominated I can be
aggressive Etc because presidents don't
want fed chairs to hike rates going to
an election year okay let's go probably
for political reasons the rate hike was
deferred sort of like Xi Jinping is only
letting people out of lockdown after uh
you know after you got whatever you call
it reelected or you know a supreme
leader for Life whatever whatever term
you would use for that right the the
Chinese Congress that happened recently
he went easier on lockdown he felt he
could make a policy change once he was
Secure and the same way I think that's
probably what happened is now Powell's
like running this 80s rerun of okay I'll
hike raids to the moon be starting from
something near zero as opposed to near
four percent and uh and an economy that
is being you know stimulated to within
each of its life for the last 10 years
and everybody was not positioned
correctly for this they all had these
Jack antic long-term bonds they were all
faked out they didn't have time to adapt
rate to the moon and then what happens
if you go back a little bit earlier is
up further
um so
previous tweet
okay
here yeah so just click click them and
just drill into the links sorry I'll do
it myself
um go down don't worry yeah so basically
uh click you know for example link Five
bank CPAs
yeah
so essentially all the banks realize
that they're dead in like April 2022 so
you see that uh yeah Rising rates and
considerations if you scroll down you
see what it's highlighted
anxious Bankers wondering what they
should do in reactions to large losses
so as early as early 2022 all the
bankers realized that they had just
gotten wrecked by the Fed
okay gigantic losses the FED with
surprise and all of them just got
destroyed because they had all trusted
the fed and bought huge amounts of bonds
at low rates before the fed the next
year just hiked into the moon and
destroyed all of these portfolios in the
same way at the same time okay so what
do the bankers do in reaction to large
losses they hid them
hold to maturity I call it high to
maturity they hid them to Shield their
portfolio related book capital from so
basically they wanted to like The
Regulators embedded this okay and you
can read this it's written in accounting
ease okay but essentially it's like how
do you what do you do with these
gigantic losses well you can suit them
under the rug okay so this shows again
he followed this trail of references it
shows that the central bank
and the bank regulators
have essentially covered up the FED
caused insolvency of hundreds of Banks
and when I say hundreds by the way just
go back one one more time yep
back to your tweets you've actually
tweets yeah and click uh number four
all right so first of all that's
unrealized losses actually sorry go back
one sorry uh two tweets uh click number
one then actually
September 2022
this shows that you know Kansas City fed
has this report okay which says first
that Rising interest rates readily so
they they accept responsibility in a
sense that the interest rate environment
has led to you know underlies lost
positions because you know Rising rates
make make the old bonds less valuable
and if you scroll down at the very
bottom
yeah wait sorry you see that okay a year
in 2021 only four Community Banks had
tangibility Capital rations four five
percent that number increased to 333 by
June 30th unless in other words
the Fed
increase the number of dead banks by 75x
in six months
and the FED do that
and get notified depositors
They're All Dead all the banks are dead
or like what some very large fraction of
them right Stanford's going to study you
can Google Stanford's study of like 4
800 Banks uh Google Google like uh
Stanford 4 800 Banks Oh Come
um Sanford uh 4 800 Banks Seb
s at suffer than n
or Stanford 4 800 Banks 4800 thanks do
you mean the paper by uh Jang mat Vos
pikorski and seru yeah I think that's
the one that's right yeah that's that
first one that first one right oh yeah
went through a bunch of 10 cues you know
maybe maybe you've read it already
Lawrence um so 2.2 trillion loss right
and point is
svb was being presented at the time that
I put out that tweet okay SC was
presented as something that risky Tech
gamblers brought upon themselves it was
like VC bets there's your fault that you
know like your account was only zero
there was some bailout or something like
that right what actually happened was
the FED killed not just svb but lots of
other Banks the bank Regulators who you
paid didn't do their job didn't tell you
the depositor that the banks were bust
it's uh you know you paid for all the
regulation you got another protection
and um
the banks themselves certainly you know
you go to these websites and what do
they have I know it's EU but the EU
tells you hey there's cookies on the
website click right that's in your face
that the bank has cookies on their
website you know it's on your face
whether the bank is insolvent
okay so it's it's like San Francisco San
Francisco you pay for the police you get
all the all you you pay for the police
and you get none of the protection
is this narrative
now of course they've now moved the ball
forward a little bit since the last time
I spoke which is yes now they've
realized that everybody knows that many
banks are bussed which banks are bust we
don't know until you actually have a big
friend because you know these are 10
cues it's like quarterly I don't know
what their real-time you know numbers
are and some of them have some of them
have Bond losses some of them have lost
in their loan book other things who
knows which banks are actually dead or
not it's a it's like shorteners bank
right it's a cat dead or alive right so
um so what they've done now is they've
done this gigantic essentially money
printing thing this btfp program where
it was supposed to be 25 billion dollars
and not be used now it's already past
whatever 100 billion dollars and you
know jpmc estimates 2 trillion already
Arthur Hayes thinks it's 4 trillion
um and so all that money is there and
interior it's loans as opposed to
purchases but probably they'll roll over
the loans all the money is there now to
put bailout the banks behind when when
people are wiring money out from dead
Banks well the FED is backstopping them
right so they're they're making it less
likely the banks die in a fire
um though some of them still will
because they won't take the btfp loans
they'll just try and risk a bank loan
um but uh
but they have caused a giant cloud of
money to now arise and some of it is
going to money market funds and someone
is going to Big Banks but essentially
we've turned traditional Finance into
like a Giant floating cloud of digital
money that is seeking the highest return
and highest safety
and that is just completely destabilize
the bank so they don't understand what
that is it's actually very similar to
the D5 world where D5 all this money
seeking yield constantly and eventually
I think some of the money is going to
seek the exit to bitcoin and that's a
hyper victimization thesis but let me
let me pause here that gives you that
gives you the method of the madness so
yes thank you for that that overview and
I want to get uh Larry in here in just a
second to react to all of that that you
just laid out but first I just do want
to ask a follow-up about the BET itself
first of all
following both you and James Medlock on
Twitter it looks like you've moved the
money into escrow and are working out
legal details is that kind of the status
of things right now in terms of the
actual bet I have the money I posted it
in an ethereum address
um we are working out legal details
there's very I mean one of the things
that happened is um this guy Matt Levine
made various allegations which are
untrue in an article like oh it's you
know Market manipulation blah blah it's
completely untrue
um I'm not selling any Bitcoin
um holding Bitcoin until the U.S dollars
along the zero currency because the
delegation would be that you own a lot
of Bitcoin so you're trying to pump up
the price to make more than the one or
two million dollars that you've bet yeah
exactly that's his allegation which is
false and I've rebutted it publicly
um first obviously exclusive had Bitcoin
forever but the thing is I didn't
actually even froze this bet I tested it
right it was somebody else who posted
and so on they're poking at me
um third is that uh this is like a Simon
erlich cell event it's like 90 I can't
actually be you know money on it it was
meant to prove a point about this
financial Crest and you can see my state
of mind if you go and look at the tweets
since like March 11th like essentially
we're gonna do these piecing together at
this end that I just kind of described I
was trying to figure out what the heck
I'm looking at real estate Bank okay so
it's a sorry so it's a you're saying
it's a Julian Simon Paul Ehrlich style
bat who famously made a bet trying to
see you know uh you know Ehrlich was was
predicting that we're going to be
overpopulated and commodity prices are
going to go crazy Julian Simon said no
let's bet on this basket of Commodities
and Simon famously won that bet so he he
actually believed that this was not
going to happen and he won the the bet I
guess that's the one question I want to
get to you before we have Larry weigh in
here is like do you actually believe
Bitcoin is going to a million dollars or
is it really just to draw is it like a
you know drawing attention to this
problem that you've laid out I think
Bitcoin will eventually go to a million
dollars
um I do think there are some Pro Arthur
Hayes also thinks it's going a million
like basically I think we're now in the
the final stages of Fiat in a sense like
they've realized that they cannot
um they tried this rate hiking thing
they buckled now printing again so we're
in like and we're all in a base of high
Invasion and unlike 2008 the US dollar
is no longer too big to fail like it has
two scale competitors in the form of BTC
and R B and God help us if r b if they
open the capital account in China's
nuclear currency then we're all under
some horrible surveillance team even the
dollar itself is being turned into
something pretty terrible I think with
this fed now thing which is not
technically a cbdc but it's got many of
the negative aspects of TPC for civil
liberties so
um so you know the thing is timing is
timing is hard prepping is easy okay so
I don't know exactly when this is going
to happen but I wanted to draw attention
to the combination of a lot of small
Banks being destroyed with money being
centralized in in big Banks or money
market funds B the cryo exits being
closed C an enormous amount of printing
beginning and then indeed admits all of
this in July push up the timetable
evidently for the FED Now launch we
should make it easy to impose Capital
controls and lock you in to a system of
potentially devalued dollars right now
right and clear by the way do I think
all that is like intentional and so on
no I mean like you think about for
example camouflage you could have a
soldier who camouflaged themselves and
they put like you know the the stuff on
their face and they've got the snap
rifle or you could have a snake which
has evolved camouflage and it was never
intentional it just kind of happened
right and I think this system is more of
the latter where it's like a merchant
and a father or anything that's obvious
is kind of caught out so the whole thing
evolved for people lie to themselves and
lie to you about what they're actually
doing not not fully understanding what
it is but what it is it's like basically
trying to essentially do a stealthy
evaluation of the dollar like what
dollar you're predicted is actually now
happening that they're monetizing the
debt they're now in the early stages of
that how fast it happens I don't know
but it's much better to be aware of that
and then execute on whatever digital
prep measures the digital prefer before
uh and then you know see if that happens
again whether that's 90 days where it's
900 days TBD but I do think we're in the
last stages of the field at the
beginning
Larry I think abolishes laid it out
pretty thoroughly there um and abolish I
don't know if you're wearing a mic on
your lapel or something but we are
getting a lot of interference I don't
know if there's any adjustments you can
do there
um let me play uh a clip from uh Fed
chair Jerome Powell expressing a
contrary opinion about the state of the
banking system and then Larry I'd like
you to weigh in and tell me you know do
you side more with Balaji do you side
more with pal or do you have a totally
different take on all this
system is sound and resilient with
strong our ranking system is sound and
resilient with strong capital and
liquidity
we will continue to closely monitor
conditions in the banking system and are
prepared to use all of our tools as
needed to keep it safe and sound
what do you think Larry
no I think I'm on biology side when it
comes to the soundness of the banking
system or lack of soundness of the U.S
banking system and I think he's doing a
real service by drawing attention to
what's been going on
now I don't follow
that hyperinflation is going to be the
result of it uh but yeah the the banking
systems in in very deep trouble
and it's because of Central Bank policy
and even if the FED hadn't tightened
monetary policy there would have been a
problem
because the loose monetary policy that
the FED ran during the pandemic and then
didn't
withdraw when uh the need for
that much liquidity was had vanished
uh gave us the 8.9 inflation that we had
last year
and that's driven up long-term interest
rates and the long-term rise in
long-term interest rates is what makes
the value of long-term bonds crater
so
the FED is in a hard place where they're
trying to fight inflationary
expectations and in that way bring down
long-term interest rates
but that requires them to tighten money
and with the side effect of raising
short-term interest rates and so that
also can can contribute to raising the
whole term structure of interest rates
but we have a banking system where as
biology said
Banks uh many many banks bought
long-term bonds because that seemed to
be
the only way to earn any yield
and The Regulators encourage them to do
it on the under the premise that
treasuries are a safe security
well they're not going to default
they're safe in that sense but they do
have a lot of interest rate risk when
you buy a 20-year treasury bond so when
interest rates go up the value of those
bonds goes down
and that's a problem they should have
been aware of and that the regulate the
bank should have been aware of and that
The Regulators should have been aware of
one of the scandals uh is that when they
did stress tests last year of the
largest banks
they simulated what would happen to
their net worth if interest rates Rose
from zero to two percent
and that's as high as they went
and at two percent SBB would have been
okay
if they had you know tested for three
percent four percent where are we now
four and three quarter percent interest
rates they would have seen a lot more
trouble Than The Regulators wanted to
see so there has been a failure to
look deeply enough and as biology said
uh they haven't been very public about
the
problems that are at the banks and the
the study he cited by the working paper
by four economists
uh the title of which is monetary
tightening and U.S Bank fragility in
uh shows that it's not just bonds that
have fallen in value it's also mortgages
and other long-term loans at fixed rates
that banks have made
and they these authors estimate that
assets have declined by 10 percent
across all banks
and most banks have less than 10 percent
Capital so that's pretty serious and at
the worst bags it's a bigger decline so
their estimate is that something like
190 banks are at a risk of insolvency to
the point where
just wiping out the uninsured depositors
isn't going to be enough they're going
to be losses to the FDIC if they need to
pay back insured depositors
so so that's a problem and in the last
week we've seen the injection of funds
by the FED in the form of loans to the
banks
and I looked at the fed's uh balance
sheet and total Fed Credit was up 211
billion last week so it is hundreds of
billions it's not yet trillions it's not
yet rivaling the size of the QE programs
in recent years
but if they added 200 billion every week
for a while it adds up now
hopefully they won't need to add that
much
um and but even if they do need to lend
that much to Banks it doesn't follow
that we get expansion in the monetary
base or the the total fed liabilities or
in money held by the public because the
FED can sterilize the loans they make to
banks that is they can offset their
effect on monetary aggregates
by selling other assets selling
securities out of the fed's portfolio
and the FED has trillions of dollars
worth of securities
and in that way they can keep total Fed
Credit unchanged that's what they did in
2008.
uh they sorry they didn't keep total Fed
Credit
from rising the monetary base Rose quite
dramatically they kept money held by the
public from rising
and they sterilize those expansions by
paying interest on reserves in a sense
paying Banks not to create more deposits
so they can do that again they can pay a
little more on reserves now that in a
sense kicks the can down the road the
FED is itself is already insolvent it's
worth mentioning the FED itself has a
very long Bond portfolio and it's lost
enough money to wipe out its capital
but that doesn't stop them
in a Fiat money system nobody can redeem
their liabilities so they can keep on
printing they can keep
employees and they can keep on lending
to Banks
but they don't need to engage in a hyper
expansion in order to lend more to Banks
um and even if they lend more to Banks
and don't neutralize the effect on the
monetary base they can neutralize the
effect on money held by the public so it
depends on whether the FED will take
those steps
and it if they're at all serious about
keeping inflation contained they will
have to take those steps now that we've
seen in other countries the kind of
problem where central banks issue a
blanket guarantee that they're going to
print enough money to save all the banks
the Philippines did that in 1997 and the
result was inflation and a sharp
devaluation of the Philippine currency
uh but in the U.S we bailed out the
Savings and Loan industry without that
causing an inflation in fact that
happened in a period of falling
inflation
so I'm skeptical of the prediction of
hyperinflation in the U.S and
correspondingly I'm skeptical of hyper
bitcoinization as a result
uh let's start let's talk first about
hyperinflation what do you say to that
skepticism apology
so the thing is that actually I'm trying
to find this paper I mean there's a
difference between hyperinflation and
Hyper bitcoinization those are actually
distinct and it's actually possible for
example to have something like uh you
know what happened to Argentina where uh
you had both a massive economic
contraction massive and uh the dollar
tripled in value
um like relative to so people were
trying to the economy was Contracting
and people were trying to exit it at the
same time
that is what like hyper bitcoinization
looks like where
um you know you could potentially even
have some prices fall or you could have
weird things happening where like I
don't know housing prices fall and food
prices rise or things are all just
Haywire because they've broken some of
the normal relationships where they're
still hiking rates but they're then
bailing out the banks Wilder hiking
rates normal relationship between High
rates and tag managers has been broken
so just like stagflation is in like a
region of of the graph where you think
that you know inflation unemployment are
traded off but maybe they could happen
at the same time
um I don't know whether typical economic
relationships will will hold so I don't
have a strong thesis on all the internal
dynamics of the US or more generally
Western economies I do think that more
and more people want to exit them
and that's that's what
hyperbitronization means really or more
generally it means USD BTC is the one
number that is really hard for the FED
to fake because you can't manipulate it
can't freeze or seize or inflate Bitcoin
that simple constraint of the fixed 21
million with the Infinity of the FED
Bitcoin exists outside the fed's video
game okay like you think about the FED
as like the system administrator of all
the banks and actually indirectly you
know through the other central banks all
the banks under you know like like the
bank of Japan and so all these other you
know simple banks that sort of fold into
the FED where it did these like you know
announcements of joint central banks
um or joining down to other central
banks the FED can you know it doesn't
have a full cbdc yet of course but it
can order any account Frozen it can
print money and do all these things
because all these banks are effectively
licensed by it directly or indirectly so
it can make all the numbers go up within
this video game it can't however create
like loaves of bread outside it can't uh
affect China's RMB that's its own video
game and it cannot affect the number of
BTC right those are separate systems
right those are genuinely Sovereign in a
sense the free currency true currency
pairs in the world argue are like USD
RMB RMB BTC and BTC USD right those are
like the three truly independent billion
person-ish economic systems
and so the bitcoinization thesis or the
hyper Bank close issues is that as the
U.S economy just gets worse and worse
and more unpredictable people will seek
a safe haven not in Money Market funds
and big Banks which are in my view a
trap in this cycle in a way that they
were not in 2008.
um are they a trap because I think you
will probably have some form of either
Capital control or a Fed now like set of
controls and so on imposed on them you
may not be able to wire money out you
may have various kinds of things that
make it difficult for you to buy
cryptocurrency from their it may be like
uh it was a hotel California or
something like you go in and you don't
come out or something right
um You can never leave yes you can never
leave that's right and by the capital
control thing you know someone's like oh
yeah apology will tell me when the
capital control is coming I'm like do
you take a look at this restrict Act
like that's even intense and that's just
any transaction like forget forget it if
they're willing to throw you in jail
20 years in prison and 250 000 fine for
using a VPN to access Tick Tock yeah
absolutely that will include Capital
controls like if they if they really
want to do that right like clearly
that's like that's far in excess of just
a normal cap control so so that is a
thesis is you could have a contraction
and you could have people who want to
escape the economy into something that
is like a goal or in this case a digital
gold now by the way it doesn't have to
be Bitcoin you could go to oil or you go
to Commodities or you go to hard Goods
of some kind you could go to another
foreign banking system some you know
Indians that move their their money to
India I never thought I'd see the day
when Indian Banks were considered more
trustery than American Banks but here we
are and they are by many I mean Indian
Founders right and so you can go to gold
which many Indians do yes that's right
and I know you've written books on on
gold uh Lawrence and I'm I'm always Pro
gold I think gold is you know Eternal
it's got a lot of good properties it's
hard to transport it metal detectors
will will set it off it's pretty heavy
it's a liquid you know there's our
downsides as you know but gold is also
reasonable it will hold its value okay
um
but uh but basically that that's a
thesis is I don't have a strong thesis
on the internal mechanics of you know
like the wings on a plane are in a
certain way when a plane is flying but
when a plane is crashing the wings can
be all akimbo right so they don't have a
strong thesis on what's going to happen
in this unprecedented time of continuing
to hike breaks while they're printing
trillions and and breaking normal
relationships I don't have a strong you
know opinion of that just that things
are going to break in bizarre Ways by
the way we still have this whole opaque
derivative thing out there where who the
heck knows what's going to happen to
that we have massive commercial real
estate crashes this year where all these
leases aren't getting renewed I've heard
some stuff about like Insurance
um there's a debt ceiling coming up in
June a lot of different things are going
to probably blow up so I don't know
exactly how it's going to blow up I just
think that people are going to want to
stay clear and I think that's a thesis
on getting into Bitcoin
yeah I think it's I think it's
reasonable to expect uh people to move
some of their savings into Bitcoin in
order to diversify away from the dollar
when inflation in the dollar uh goes up
and becomes less predictable
but hey we had uh nine percent inflation
last year at the peak we had 10
inflation in Europe and Great Britain
and we don't see people adopting Bitcoin
as a medium of Exchange in those
countries
so when people talk about hyper
bitcoinization I
I understand them to be talking about
the adoption of Bitcoin as an everyday
money as a medium of Exchange
I've studied what makes countries switch
from their domestic currency to a new
currency uh for example when Latin
American countries dollarized
and it takes fairly High inflation more
than 10 percent I would say more like 20
percent
and Rising with no correction in sight
and until we see that I don't expect to
see major movement out of dollars into
alternatives
and one of the Alternatives is gold the
gold actually has a larger installed
base than Bitcoin right now the monetary
type gold that is just coins and bullion
and ETFs in the hands of the public
is
like four and a half trillion dollars so
that's nine times the value of the
Bitcoin at the moment now it's not
easily spendable as Bitcoin is but
people are digitizing gold and making it
transferable online uh and so that may
become an alternative if the dollar
really becomes unstable
but I I place pretty low odds on our
getting 20 inflation in the US anytime
soon
um well so let me show you just this
here's this interesting graph can I can
I put this graph on screen the share
screen yeah it's just this is actually
from seven days ago but I think it's
continued is that's an interesting chart
where banks are crashing and Bitcoin is
soaring because it is for the first time
showing something that we have theorized
that of people Now understand that it's
got I'm not saying there aren't any
failure modes with Bitcoin for example
you can lose your private Keys it can be
stolen and so on and so forth right but
it's an orthogonal modes from losing it
at the bank right so it's a
diversification that's so these are back
share prices all right
the big share prices that's right
um so these are the three worst case
scenarios yeah no I know I know so you
know like it saves me banks lots of
banks especially mid-sized banks have
seen their fair prices fall pretty far
in the last couple
so
um the reason it's just an interesting
way of looking at that you're starting
to see Bitcoin Banks like pull away
right in a sense of becoming excluded
originally as being an alternative to
the banks and now in a literal sense it
is right
um to your points uh you know one thing
I've said on Twitter you know many times
is I'm not a Bitcoin maximalist
um you know but you know I do think we
are all Bitcoin Max boost now in the
sense of
having focus on one asset as a Lifeboat
to get out is important after which
there can be many of the theological
disputes tribal disputes that are common
in crypto and what I think is actually
you can imagine just to take a Sci-Fi
scenario for a second that um you've
seen some stuff where uh for example
Florida's come out against the cbdc
yeah yes let me play I actually have a
clip of DeSantis talking about that so
let me play that and then you can talk a
little bit about uh DeSantis in Florida
and
cbdc Society uh to any way they can get
into society uh to exercise their agenda
they will do it so what the Central Bank
digital currency is all about is
surveilling Americans and controlling
behavior of Americans today I'm here to
call on the legislature to pass
legislation to expressly forbid the use
of cbdc as money within Florida's
Uniform Commercial Code this will ensure
that Florida continues to be a state
that supports innovation in the
financial sector through the market
while protecting against government
surveillance over your personal finances
foreign
could you just explain just let's not
assume everyone knows what a cbdc is so
just briefly explain why that what that
is why you think it's a problem and why
you're approving of what DeSantis is
doing here
well so so what's the cbdc a CDC stands
for Central Bank digital currency and uh
you know to first order it is something
that's a lot like Bitcoin or ethereum
but it is run by Central Bank and so
every dollar can be tracked in the
ecosystem it's more programmable
um and that's different than how the
current banking system is set up where
uh you know we're not getting too
technical it's more opaque it's all
spread out across different databases as
opposed to like one Consolidated
database where you can track literally
every single dollar moving everywhere
right so from a technology standpoint
the cbdc is an efficiency and
transparency and programmability
improvement over you know the status quo
if that was if you were living in a high
trust Society you might be able to do
that right the problem is we're not in a
Hydra Society unfortunately or in a
society where these genuine productivity
games unfortunately will come with a
with a hook it's like a it was like a
sweet you know where it's got a a hook
in the bait and the the hook is total
surveillance total control
um ability to freeze account drain
accounts it's like the euphemism of
consumer to government payments you know
and I actually have a thing on this here
maybe you can uh put this up
the CBC light
to push the timetable up to lunch in
July and um
okay great so
um if you look at my tweet on this uh
here I just paste it into chat
um
so
you put that up on screen Central Bank
digital
all right
there you go yeah so this essentially
makes a point that people say oh fed now
it's not a cbdc
technically it's different than a cmdc
so it's important the difference from a
technical standpoint from a civil
liberty standpoint the difference isn't
that important the reason is if you
scroll down and look at the screenshots
at the end of this post
[Music]
um
so click that first one
so first point is that everything gets
centralized through the Fed
okay number one if you go if you hit
right arrow yeah yeah
that's highlighted there it says
complies with applicable controls they
just slid that one in there right
step three is compliance applicable
controls guess what that's anything that
can literally mean you can't spend too
much money you can't you have to spend
money right now you uh can't send it to
this person with this immigration status
blah blah blah every kind of possible
crazy control that the current system is
not it's it's someone set up to do that
so there's a difference if it's all
centralized and it's all in database you
can have crazy fine-grain controls then
go to the third slide
so you know they're like all the great
payment tests and again in a hydro
Society this sounds great but you know
what I see when I see uh consumer to
government and government consumer I see
consumerator Garmin drain your account
and garbage consumer stimulus right like
basically helicopter dollars and you
know free is in your account you know
it's the government right
um among other things and uh so so that
is like what a cbdc or fed now actually
is and
[Music]
um
but it's worth it's worth
differentiating between those right
because the cbdc is an actual you know
coin or currency that the FED is holding
that it's like you're holding your money
with the FED instead of at a bank
account whereas the FED now is kind of
like a instant payment system
um is it are you saying there's no
meaningful difference in terms of the
kind of control that can be exerted
through the two systems there are some
differences like you know it might be a
little bit harder to track every single
dollar with that now than it is to the
cbdc okay but uh there's there's some
things like in terms of transparency and
stuff like that are different but let's
say you know the FED now is like the
federal PayPal and the CBD would be like
a federal ethereum okay roughly speaking
okay
um go ahead Lawrence did you disagree
that yeah I think there is an important
difference uh between cbdc which I am
also very alarmed about the prospect
effect of and fed now which I'm not so
alarmed about because fed now you keep
your account at a private Commercial
Bank
and like you say the the data then is
more distributed uh whereas with the
cbdc there is one database that where
the FED kind in real time watch every
transaction so that's scary
but fed now is not that it's just a way
of making checks clear faster
basically so I mean I share your concern
about cbdc but I don't think fed now is
the thing to be alarmed about
the difference is that uh okay a cbdc
you have an account on the books of the
Fed
it's not a coin I mean people have
sometimes described it that way but it's
not a coin it's it's the FED account
everybody can have an account on the
books of the fed and then they can track
what happens with your account
whereas fednow is speeding up transfers
between private bank accounts
Yes except uh so I agree with you that
the cbdc would have even greater and
more granular levels of control but if
you look at some of the documentation
that I was just pasting in
um it does appear and I was looking at
some of the you know some of the API
stuff I may be wrong about this but you
can go and look at the docs that uh that
they can impose applicable controls that
they can or they're adding the ability
to do equipment
um it does look like something where
unfortunately I have to think
adversarially with respect to this
government right and uh for example you
saw what they did to the truckers so
they did to you know in Canada yeah yeah
even even with respect of Russia you
might actually argue it was more
Justified like the Canadian truckers I
think much less justifiable it's like a
base towards this protest Russia that's
act they actually did you know Act of
war and so fine I can understand that
right nevertheless the revelation of
that level of financial weapon is out
there right clearly even before you know
a cbdc let alone you know fed now
um before Let's see we see they're
freezing accounts they're doing this
type of stuff
and so of course it's going to be used
for political purposes is my view
um
the alternative to that is actually uh
that many of these states I think so
just taking a few of the points so
coming all the way back up
um if you take the observation that for
example uh you know DeSantis has come
out against CBC he's also got a Florida
State guard like he's making you know
make America States again right
Federalism is on the rise and uh you
know for the last 10 years or so states
have been breaking away from the feds
both left and right on not just
Sanctuary cities of course but on gun
laws drug laws abortion laws crypto
everything right and crypto in
particular uh you know you have for
example Texas says the right to buy sell
Sin receive Bitcoin shall not be
infringed Wyoming and Tennessee have the
Dow laws uh Mississippi and Montana have
Bitcoin mining protection acts the
Florida mayor uh accepts the salary of
Bitcoin Colorado accepts taxes Bitcoin
New Hampshire is friendly to
cryptocurrency okay so
um what I anticipate is that this is
going to become a major political issue
but not in the typical left right way
more of a thorough versus States issue
with
um more and more States potentially
doing something like the opening gold
window
okay so you want sci-fi scenario
yeah all right okay here's the Sci-Fi
scenario okay
um maybe actually over the next few
months okay we get something and I'm
writing eventually here's a preview of
an article I'm reading okay reopening
the gold window except it's the digital
gold window so we have
bitcoin.florida.gov
bitcoin.texas.gov
bitcoin.wyoming.gov okay and so on and
what you can do is it's a simple Bitcoin
exchange where you can buy and sell
Bitcoin either as a brokerage or just by
placing limit orders and these order
books
um they can use you know commercial
exchanges or they can peer with each
other okay and the state takes a cut of
this
and they are able to start holding up
their digital gold reserves like they'll
sell them and they have restored the
inter-convertibility into digital gold
that essentially reverses what Nixon did
in 1971 okay and why did they do this
well uh the scientists actually put out
some stuff on how he might actually have
state chartered Banks
um banking crypto uh as a response to
the FED trying to shut off uh banking
access to crypto at which point if you
game it out essentially if you want to
deal or anything to shut off fed wire or
ACH or other access to State Charter
Banks which would mean like cutting off
Florida simply to cut off crypto which
is probably too big a thing and If the
Fed did it it would actually show the
financial totalitarianism that he's
saying is potentially there with cbdc if
they didn't do it well then they have to
actually allow the currency of the
People by the people for the people to
not perish from this earth right
actually have a Bitcoin exchange that is
now at a government level right and so
the thing is you know you're seeing the
movie Pacific Rim
sure yes yeah so Pacific Rim it's like
these giant monsters come out of the
ocean and humans cannot fight those
giant monsters so you have to build
giant rods okay so when when you've got
to come when you've got a government
that is attacking companies you can't
beat a government with a company you can
only beat it with another government
okay so Florida or Texas has enough hit
points
to be a giant robot that can stand up to
harassment from the federal government
and I think that's what's going to come
right
and so that's a piece of it how you
actually have the rails to buy Bitcoin
open over the medium to long run that's
how I think we get State resistance is
it's the opposite of kind of how we
normally thought about it similar to the
El Salvador model where the state has
flipped to being pro-bitcoin right
showing by the way where you have a
political movement and it goes from
people thinking it's going to be banned
to becoming a national currency that's a
really really important thing okay
that's like early Christianity going
from being banned to something that
Constantine adopted right that's like
you know many many really important
political movements I can name some of
them you can think of others right yeah
it goes all the way from band to
essentially the head of state adopting
it right that's a lot of momentum there
so
so one aspect what you mentioned
Lawrence earlier
um is the rails how do you keep the
rails open I think that's what's going
to happen you're going to have States
defect and effectively realize how
profitable it is for them at the state
and local level especially when Regional
banks are getting killed this way of
being a Renaissance Regional Banks
having crypto Banks
um number two is you said okay
um how do you understand the
transactions per second and so on and so
forth and what I think actually happens
is
um again a Sci-Fi scenario
scenario on the other side of the kind
of conflicts that I think might come you
essentially have Bitcoin atheist sheets
Bitcoin monotheist States and Bitcoin
polygates
okay so Bitcoin atheist States would be
like the dollar States or the REM Envy
okay remember zones where they hate the
coin and you cannot have it in private
hands like gun control right you can't
have guns in your hands Bitcoin you
couldn't have any private hands like
FDR's gold seizure open on Cris you
can't do it that'd be the Bitcoin
atheist States Bitcoin monetary Estates
like Bitcoin maximal Estates
um you can have Bitcoin private hands in
fact that defines the state we could
have only Bitcoin and so all the
inefficients you know you have to use
lightning Network and other things you
can kind of make that stuff work it's
it's like there's various workarounds
okay
um but basically what is Haram what is
prohibited is to have any token any
usual token other than Bitcoin okay you
cannot have anything other than Bitcoin
that's like a Bitcoin monitor you see
like a Maximus and then finally I think
you'll also have Bitcoin polytheist
states which have Bitcoin as like Zeus
at the center of a bunch of gods to
speak right and Bitcoin policy states we
have Bitcoin they have ethereum they
have other kinds of things and they
would support more complicated Financial
transactions they support high capacity
blockchains and so on and so forth and
that you'll probably see in like
Financial Centers like UAE or whatever
okay so that's kind of how I see the
future evolving and uh you know so you
know I know that sounds sci-fi but
Lawrence love your thoughts yeah I uh I
favor separation of church and state and
I separation favor separation of Bitcoin
and states and all other
cryptocurrencies in state so I'm not
keen on state governments running
exchanges those should be in private
hands they should play hands off toward
private exchanges and let them do their
thing and so of course should the
federal government
so I mean that's what I think we have to
rely on to uh
preserve our monetary freedom of choice
we have to be eternally Vigilant against
encroachment of our uh rights and our
liberties by the federal government and
by the state governments
yeah I I do actually understand that
view
um but that's also why I I wouldn't call
myself an orthodox libertarian at all uh
you know like you know Lee Kuan Yew was
pretty much all over the political map
and did what what he thought was best
for the country at any one time like you
know whether it was subsidizing houses
or doing things that seemed to be for
the left or the libertarian right or
what have you he he did some combination
of policies idiosyncratic heterodox
combination policies and um and I don't
think that you can beat government
harassment
with just lawsuits
um I think like basically you need
another state to kind of be on the other
side of that uh and I think that's
what's going to happen
so
um
look at his unilateral disarmament uh if
you are if if one is not actually taking
through Bitcoin really means seriously
um it means essentially the currency of
a free people that you're not monitored
you can't be you can't have your savings
you know stolen and Frozen right but
that that has an introduction go ahead
and that's why I'm not a fan of what's
happened in El Salvador where the
government has tried to mandate that
businesses accept Bitcoin whether they
want to or not fortunately it hasn't
taken
have refused it and it's been
unenforceable
I completely understand where you're
coming from in fact there is a
difference of opinion in the community
on this sure
um but ultimately there's actually a
higher sort of standard which is is El
Salvador going to attract migrants on
net
right did it say if there is a seeming
violation of one or the other
libertarian principle but they preserve
the freedom to exit and other people are
able to exit there and if they're
choosing that jurisdiction of others
remember local trade-offs they make that
may be
um you know like incorrect by by one
Theory or another are
um
or less something that on balance
attracts people
right and I think there's actually
multiple solutions to that that's to say
for example uh the Netherlands has a
very liberal drug policy Singapore has a
very strict drug policy but arguably
they're both better than the US has this
bizarre you know bipolar cash and
release type policy where it's
simultaneously very harsh punishments
and non-punishments you know so where
Singapore not only very clear about
their their goals
uh so I I think you know
[Music]
um
when El Salvador works is a is defined
by whether it attracts citizens and now
he's actually out there recruiting I
think he is attracting citizens so we
will see if that actually ends up
working despite it not working from uh
from a theoretical stamp it works in
practice not in theory
I would be pretty surprised to see an
autocratic State attracting citizens
I I wouldn't and the reason is uh UAE is
doing it uh you know like the thing is
when you say autocracy also now this
gets really fundamental in terms of
principles right
um I mean a guy who brought the assault
brought the Army into the Congress to
stand by while they voted
sure no I understand the thing is that
basically like Lincoln suspended Hades
Corpus right
um FDR ordered gold seizures after I
ordered the Japanese internment
um
I know right but what but but here's the
thing is that uh you know
if you want to get into all the details
of this and this will be a very long
conversation
um I think uh a perhaps a cynical view
is that no matter how many how many
sanctions how many invasions how many
Clues how much inflation uh how many
violations of Rights the U.S scholarship
does how many guantanamos how many drone
strikes all of that stuff whatever it
does is defined as democracy but if
somebody wins an election they don't
like
that is not democracy that's the threat
of democracy
right whether it's to the left or to the
right okay and
um I think that's uh you know I think
we're getting to the point where
um you know for example did the Iraqis
get a vote 20 million people written
franchise for like you know 20 years
right is that a small thing or is that a
big thing that's a big thing my view
um and can you call yourself an oxy if
you're just disenfranchising people like
that willy-nilly you know who's the
authoritarian is what I'm saying right
and of course people say Oh no you're
just doing what about is a book NSA
surveillance can opt out of that the FED
did we ever vote for the Fed chair all
these people around the world who are
basically paying for the dollar
subsidization via inflation
they didn't vote for that the Arab
Spring was in part caused by the
exporting of inflation abroad and the
food prices really jacked up right so
you know when I say this you know like
the
um
I think
insofar as one wants to assert a moral
High Ground I'm not so sure it's
actually there uh and you know if you're
bristling with military base around the
world and there's a lot of coercion of
both soft and hard times whether it's
sanctions or actually outright invasions
um whether it is surveillance uh which
is hidden whether it is
um you know like uh you know various
treaty blockade if you're not
is is it is it something where everybody
really has to say around the world when
they figure whatever they want freely or
is who's the authoritarian right who's
actually imposing their will on the rest
of the world right so so that's why like
you know a small country that is
choosing to diverge from where the US is
is uh you know unless one is an
anarchist you
um you know a minarchist does believe
that there's some necessary night
Watchman State you do believe that
there's some minimal rule or Force some
minimal rule uh you know for uh you know
jails and things like this you know
certainly not a lot but enough to
maintain order
and if that state diverges from the U.S
is it necessarily quote authoritarian or
is it just Divergent from the US and
therefore it is being labeled I think
it's a very fundamental question
I I mean I think the answer would be you
know beyond the Democracy question you
know is there a fundamental respect for
you know individual rights
um which we we don't see in some of the
countries that you mentioned in terms of
just allowing people to practice
different religions dress different ways
um just you know create Free Speech
dissident speech against the government
um so I think there is still a a
meaningful difference between the U.S
and and most of the countries that yeah
last one right it's a meaningful speech
against government we just saw this
restrict act proposed right which
basically uh you know all you've seen
this entire new tablet series on
disinformation
uh no I haven't seen this so this just
came out but essentially
um
you know put out there and whatnot uh
you're seeing that intelligence agencies
were suppressing domestic speech in the
name of you know stopping quote
disinformation
um what I'm trying to say is basically
like
there there was a time when the US was
essentially
uh the US establishment won a game of
free speech in free markets and
therefore is in favor of them
and more recently you've seen that
people on the left have uh come out
against free speech that they're
previously champions of it people on the
right increasingly have come out against
three markets that were previously
champions of it because
not always winning a game of free speech
in free markets so you're seeing many
more bans on speech you're seeing many
more bands on trade I think we can all
agree those are being escalating and yet
at the same time that the
authoritarianism has been escalating the
surveillance position so too having the
claims of being so democratic
that's a that's a point I'm trying to
make is you know as authoritarianism is
escalating within the US with people
being de-platformed with bills like this
proposed completely unironically to
strip people of freedoms
um then at the same time the cries that
we're so Democratic are are rising right
that's that to me is something that
should be examined critically
um but let me you know pause there
and why why uh why is it that Bitcoin is
the Hedge against so much of that
because
um you know we've seen
speaking of authoritarian actions we've
seen the US government shut down make it
illegal to hold gold uh we've seen
um that there's all there's a sustained
campaign to go to kind of just
systematically shut down cryptocurrency
exchanges I pretty much buy into the
operation choke point to 2.0 thesis we
had Nick Carter on here talking about
that a few weeks ago
um why is it that you think Bitcoin is
particularly resistant against this
creeping if not already here
authoritarianism
wrote a couple of articles in this but
one thing I want to say is I'm not a
utopian I'm a pragmatist and uh you know
the greatest
Freedom uh you know I've heard something
like Auto liberal right like the the
greatest uh Freedom that's possible that
is consistent with still a functioning
Society right there's always tension
between the rights individual the rights
of the society and so on like you can
you can go to Extremes in either
direction
with that said
in the current like status quo Bitcoin
is a very powerful tool to protect
against abuses of both the dollar and
the Renminbi
um for essentially American dissidents
and Chinese distance if you want to put
it that way right because it can't be
frozen it can't be inflated it can't be
seized
um you can also by the way use the
private keys with something like Noster
to get you free speech right and
fundamentally I think you know orange is
the new blue jeans right at the end of
the Soviet Union
um you know the blue jeans were the
symbol of like freedom and prosperity
that's what Bitcoin is it's a global
symbol of freedom and prosperity you're
a free person if you can have Bitcoin
and you can move it around because the
state ultimately is limited in its
rights or resistance
and
um I grant that there are different
hybrids here I grant that El Salvador
may not be to everybody's liking and I'm
not living there or what have you I I
actually do think on balance he's
probably improved the lives of the
people there but I grant that people may
not like the particular formula that
that he's used uh with that said I think
that if you believe in you know free
speech and you believe in free markets
privacy rule of law approval fairness
economic stability transparency Bitcoin
is those things and the FED is not right
yeah and more generally I think
um you know the US was you know I've got
two articles here one is called uh
civilization in in Barry Weiss's uh the
free press and the second is create
protocol politics and foreign policy and
those kind of expressive domestic and
international Case respectively but just
to briefly talk about the international
Case you know for many many years the US
was the champion of the rules-based
order I'm sure you've heard that term
right and it set up a system of rules
for trade between countries and and
standards and so on and now essentially
both the Trump and buying
administrations have taken a wrecking
ball to that because the U.S no longer
wins in the rules it itself it's set up
okay now you might say well of course if
we're not winning then you know Screw
the game okay right because China's bad
okay fine
but most of the world is neither
American nor Chinese
it's four percent of those American 2010
is Chinese the 75 that's just watching
the rule of disorder smash The
Smithereens in order to get China
and they're like okay uh well I liked
this old rules-based order but America
doesn't like it anymore and I definitely
do not want to live in the greater East
Asia co-prosperity sphere 2.0 which is
what China would set up so what's my
option right and I think the option in
the in the fullness of time is going to
be
um you know what I call Great protocol
politics which is Bitcoin it's smart
contracts ethereum and sort of so forth
for trade between countries sort of like
the the law of C is a demilitarized zone
you know between countries obviously
there's ships crash into each other and
so on and so forth but there's like an
established standard for kind of the law
of the sea
so the law of gene is the you know just
like the law of the seed garbage the
seed law the chain governance the cloud
that's how States transact in this sort
of neutral zone between themselves as
Cloud Commerce becomes a bigger deal
it's like a neutral zone
um as opposed to just being under the
Chinese sort of boot for example or you
know the more chaotic and you know the
quote rules-based order that's becoming
the chaos
so that's kind of you know you asked how
do I think about this that's how the
protocols in their neutrality
again it's not perfect but it is closer
to the vision of universal rights
without discrimination against any
citizen of the internet right that we
wanted
and free speech and free marks is not
everything it's not physical safety and
whatnot but it's a lot it's a good chunk
for us right that's an abbreviated
version the longer versions are in those
articles
um I I'm going to wrap up with a couple
uh final questions for both of you
because I know it's very late over there
in Singapore
um and uh you know we've been it's been
a lot of uh Doomer type talk throughout
the stream uh you both seem to agree
that the banking system is in big
trouble they disagree on the prospect of
hyperinflation I want to bring in
um a different take real quick just to
have you both react because it's uh from
someone who I think all of us on the
stream respect Tyler Cowan uh GMU
Economist uh says this banking crisis
won't wreck the economy
um the various bailouts we've been
engaging in are not Costless uh they
might introduce more moral hazard the
next time around but it doesn't mean we
should expect a spectacular financial
crash right now more likely we'll see
increases in deposit insurance premiums
and higher Capital requirements for
financial institutions and the rational
expectation is that the U.S will will
muddle through the current problems and
patch up the present at the expense of
the Future For Better or Worse this is
how we deal with most of our crises
what do you think of that more just it's
all going to kind of work out in a you
know messy but not catastrophic way type
of take Lawrence first
uh well I have a fair amount of sympathy
for that I it might be a little
optimistic and that we don't want to
understate the insolvency of the banking
system and so the cost to taxpayers may
be higher than Tyler is allowing for
but as far as it not needing to create a
huge financial crisis much less uh
hyper expansionary monetary policy I
think he's right about that
and what about you obligation is that uh
easier nerves at all to you know
consider that less catastrophic scenario
I think that um I mean obviously it'd be
good if that was the case uh I think
uh I think that the situation today is
just very different than 2008 because
there are scale competitors to USD I
think the background inflation rate is
very high I think this is a consumer
crisis
basically it was just guys and
skyscrapers trading piece of paper with
markdowns yeah
um and uh you know with some like I
think there's WAMU and whatnot and
officers there but for the most part we
don't recall
here's the Long View of kind of the the
macro situation we we brought this up
when we were talking with uh Arnold
cling and Lynn Alden so this show the
blue line at the top shows the federal
debt to GDP ratio and that's the line
that looks totally uh uh uh kind of a a
historical like there's no precedent for
that we're at new levels of debt to GDP
the red line interest rates you see post
2020 obviously spiking up the green line
inflation also spiking up
um
given this situation
how do you think it all shakes out uh
Larry because I mean we haven't really
talked about the role that you know debt
to GDP
um and just deficit spending in general
um plays in all this
wow so the the debt problem really is a
problem and it's hard to find examples
of countries that have been that
indebted
especially not even as a result of
exiting a big war but have taken on that
much debt just in
normal times who have gotten out of it
without inflating it away
so the the higher the debt goes the
higher the probability that we're going
to see
a return to double-digit inflation in
the U.S
and so that's and that will derange the
economy the way it did in the 70s and
80s so that's not a welcome Prospect
let me uh let me ask for a kind of a
final question for
um apology here uh you know so much of
what we're talking about here is the the
collapse of trust in a lot of American
institutions Global institutions
um it's it's been broken you know more
for I mean it's been going down for
years if not decades these past few
years it's taken a huge hit
how do you reckon it's actually the best
way on the individual level to operate
in the increasingly trustless world that
we find ourselves in
well so first of all I want to say I'm
actually I'm not a Doomer there's
actually a good term called Doomer
Optimus right where
uh we're basically like you know you
might think that the old system is
crashing but you know for example I have
a book called the network State on what
like that new system might look like
um on how you can start new countries in
the event the old system is actually you
know falling away I do think if you want
my mental model I think it's like the
time before World War one where you had
all the kings and that that world seemed
Eternal the monarchs and so on but
underneath there was the churning of
technology in the industrial revolution
and various movements and then that all
just burst forward after you know during
World War One and I think in the same
way we have this digital thing that's
been building and we have these old
institutions that seem Eternal and I
think the strain tensions are going to
be sort of revealed with this with this
crisis but we'll see what happens
um and what we want is a vision for
what's on the other side uh and uh I
think we want something that protects
civil liberties and that protects free
markets and that reflects the best of
American values
um and I do think that's possible I
think we have to actually
have a model in our heads of what
happens if I love Tyler I think he's
amazing whatever Tyler is not actually
right this is actually a big crisis but
if it's something like what Donald
talked about where it's actually the you
know the inflationary
um or the printing the money now
actually I digress because Zach you
asked a different question so why don't
you ask your question again yeah I I
would just like to hear your advice for
you know your your laying out you know
your your Doomer Optimist you're laying
out a very alarming scenario what do you
suggest on the individual level how
people think about kind of recalibrating
what they're doing
um both you know financially but also
just personally politically on on every
level like what is the what is the
proper reaction to this this news Okay
so preface with non-financial advice
right yeah
um so let's say that um I think
you know option one is you can just do
nothing and say nothing's gonna happen
State's going to take care of it option
two people can wire their money to Big
Banks or money market funds I think
that's probably uh that might be better
than leaving your money you know just in
tax somewhere but okay option three is
you hedge to some extent into Bitcoin
option four is you get to a Bitcoin from
the jurisdiction whether inside the US
like Florida or Texas or outside the US
El Salvador UAE or or you know like one
of many of them
um I think number five is you know
certainly at the same time this is
happening markets you know are seizing
up in different ways Bank prices happen
you have the rise of AI you also have uh
this third movie that's playing where
China is doing all these deals
um and I'd say I mean I I kind of think
in some ways this is the Prelude to the
camera moving to Asia Ai and crypto
um and so like the more leveraged you
can be on that that's probably better
right so certainly learning AI tools
being physically in Asia and
understanding why crypto by the way
another thing is commodities because of
the rise of AI everything digital
becomes cheap so Community cryptography
Commodities are the things that are hard
on their side because the AI can't
create people they can't fake digital
signatures and it can you know fake
natural resources so that's a compliment
that's the type of stuff that's still
there on the other side of this
instruction
um and that's what I think one should
probably do uh and of course that's that
range is all from do nothing to like
reinvent your life on this side you can
pick whatever you think is is good on
that museum
um or you can ignore me which is totally
fine and that's really your progress you
know just then buy treasuries
um you know so
a similar question for you Larry because
uh you know you just you just published
a book about the history of money and uh
the history and future of money and
um you know you make the case that
switching to a Fiat standard is
responsible for a lot of the problems
that we're facing today and you also lay
out as you said some possible paths
forward you have a different Outlook
from Balaji you don't think we're on the
brink of hyper bitcoinization but you
recognize that there are some looming
dangers ahead so what would you
recommend uh is a sustainable viable
path forward to secure kind of the the
economic and monetary stability of the
United States
yeah so Bitcoin is great at what it does
which is provide a censorship resistant
method of payment it censorship
resistant because it doesn't go through
central banks when you send somebody
Bitcoin that transaction is not being
cleared through a central bank which you
know can whitelist and Blacklist who it
likes and doesn't like
but it isn't well designed for the role
of a commonly accepted medium of
exchange that is you know for paying
your rent or buying your coffee
because its purchasing power is just too
volatile
and the volatility isn't because it's
young it hasn't diminished with age it
hasn't diminished when the market cap
has been higher it's built into Bitcoin
because the release schedule is
pre-programmed and fixed so the supply
of Bitcoin the quantity of coins in
circulation doesn't respond to a run-up
in the purchasing power
even in the long run and so it doesn't
stabilize the value of Bitcoin
uh unlike the classical gold standard
where the supply of gold does respond in
the long run
to an increase in the purchasing power
gold because it pays miners to dig a
Little Deeper when the purchasing power
is high and that brings the purchasing
power back down
so if I had my druthers
um
I think the way to de-politicize money
and have a money of stable purchasing
power
is to resurrect in some Modern form a
commodity standard a gold standard we've
got lots of gold it's still sitting
there in Central Bank vaults we could
make use of it
uh is that politically likely no unless
we have a really terrible crisis
uh which not something I want to hope
for but personally I advise people to
diversify their Investments if you have
more than 100 250 000 in a U.S Bank get
it out of there
get the excess out of there into
something safer
uh if you have all your money in
long-term bonds you diversify away from
there uh so follow the advice of Wu-Tang
financial and diversify your bonds uh I
think inflation is more of a threat than
the market currently does so I think
inflation index bonds are underpriced
and that's a way to hedge against
inflation although you do have to worry
about whether the treasury will make
good on its promise to compensate you
for inflation they've they've done okay
with that so far
and so that's that's my personal
financial advice warning I'm not a
licensed investment advisor
and what about the role of actual
competition in money uh is there a way
to improve that and and can that yeah so
more figure out you know what what is
actually the soundest
yeah so people should be free to exit
from the dollar into whatever they think
is a better currency whether it's euros
Swiss Francs gold or Bitcoin
and that provides a little bit of
discipline on central banks
um not many people are going to do that
as long as inflation rates are moderate
and that's okay because it's not that
important as long as inflation is
moderate
but as inflation Rises it's becomes
increasingly important to have those
exit options
so it's important not to let the
authorities cut those off to close the
exits so I'm as concerned about that as
biology is
okay well thank you Larry thank you
Balaji we'll be watching the bets and
you know thank you for starting this
conversation uh with it I think that
there's a lot of important underlying
issues that that you've laid out here
today that are important to draw
people's attention to so
um in in that sense you know your bet I
think has accomplished something
um and uh thank you also to all the
viewers who tuned in today we'll be back
next week uh same time on uh on Thursday
and we'll see you then thanks
thanks